with its Rolling Hills and rich soil the
countryside around Rome has been home to
some of the finest Vineyards in the
country since the Roman Empire
the wine appreciated for its light body
refreshing during these summer days
but Francisco de sancti says this could
become a thing of the past as extreme
weather conditions change the quality of
the grape
was a young wine the climate has had a
huge impact the wine is heavier now even
if we Harvest earlier the alcohol
content is higher some will say it's a
more bodied wine this year because of
high temperatures and humidity we have
lots of parasites which are ruining the
grapes
it's estimated that the loss in wine
production this year will be around 30
to 40 percent because of what Italians
like to call the crazy weather
since the beginning of the year Italy
has seen severe drought followed by
torrential rain which caused deadly
floods and now in the midst of a
stifling Heat Wave and wildfires have
become a huge concern
the Civil protection is on alert from
this control room in Rome it coordinates
the response to wildfires across Italy
and there are currently several fires
raging in the southern region of Reggio
Calabria and on the island of Sicily
they have also deployed to help tame
fires in Greece there are environmental
conditions which are very favorable to
ignition and spreading of big fires and
so the risk is very high so the
population must pay attention to the
risk because high temperatures with wind
they are causing the possibility that
the fire can really spread and become
very big principally the damage is to to
environment and to the woods it's a
concern that is always on David
agentile's mind during the summer season
his agricultural Cooperative has had to
plan and find creative ways to grow its
organic produce sunflower is a really
good protector of the zucchini because
when it grows it has really big leaves
really really big leaves that can make
shade zucchini is a plant that actually
like the sun and makes a lot of of
zucchini if it has Sun but every plant
doesn't like really hot sun and too high
UV on on their lips
Italy Prides itself as one of the
largest agriculture producers in the EU
but climate change will have a profound
impact on the land and people's way of
life but Abdul Hamid al-jazeera Rome